President Trump gives an uncomfortable
press conference to say the least the
left decides an MTF are the same as
world war ii allies and the media
decides that everything is hitler i'm
ben shapiro this is the ben shapiro show
[Music]
okay so we're going to go through in
detail president Trump's unnecessary and
ridiculous press conference yesterday he
said a couple of things that were true
and then he did something that I thought
was just morally egregious we're going
to talk about all of it in the most
fair-minded way that I think that we can
we're going to go through all of the
evidence on what President Trump said
we're going to talk about the media
response to all of it so get ready for a
very very full show but before we get to
any of that first I want to say thank
you to our sponsors over at rapper so
you lose your wallet you lose your phone
you lose your keys my wife is famous for
losing her phone she loses it all the
time or at least she did until we
started using tracker eight years ago
tracker changed everything when they
released their first tracking device and
now they have something called the
tracker pixel it is the lightest
Bluetooth tracking device on the market
it's like a coin size device and you
stick it on your keys or your wallet or
your cat okay when you misplace an item
that has a tracker pixel attached to it
you use your smartphone and 90 decibel
alert will help you find it in seconds
it even has powerful LED lights you can
find anything in the dark by the way
tracker works so well the way it works
is you put the program on your phone and
you attach it to your keys the actual
tracker devices your keys and then when
you hit the one on your keys if your
phone is silent you've lost your phone
it will override the silent phone it
will override the fact that you put your
phone on silent it'll ring so that you
know exactly where your phone is never
lose your wallet or your phone or your
keys again that's what tracker is for
it's the tracker comm the tracker comm
enter promo code Ben you get 20% off any
order that subtract our comm track our
comm that tracker comm use promo code
bending at 20% off any order and also
use that promo code Ben so they know
that we sent you has made my marriage in
s similarly better and so you should use
it for yourself as well save yourself
time and effort okay so yesterday
president Trump is doing a press
conference it's supposed to be
infrastructure week ok I'm getting there
is something hilarious about the fact
that every week with President Trump is
a new week in which he declares the
theme right it's American jobs week or
its infrastructure week or it's
relaxation week well this week was
another infrastructure week and
naturally he decided
to burn every Bridge in sight in honor
of infrastructure week so he gave his
statement on Monday right he gave you
yesterday and I talked briefly about or
Tuesday and I talked briefly about that
statement yesterday yes he said sorry to
give the statement Monday he gave an
original statement Saturday on
Charlottesville lending of a statement
Monday which we talked about yesterday
and then after we finished the show
yesterday Trump went out and did in
unnecessary press conference he was not
asked to do the press conference for
anyone no one wanted him to do the press
conference his own people didn't want
him to do a press conference but Trump
obviously had something on his mind and
he wanted to say it and so he said to
the press here now I'm going to take
questions so he began he basically to
sum up the press conference he spoke
about a few different topics he spoke
about the outlet what he called the alt
left which would be an Tifa presumably
alt left is a term I believe coined by
Sean Hannity as sort of a councillor to
be outright it I've never liked to turn
alt left because it sort of legitimizes
all right there is no alt left there is
just the hard left and Antipa but in any
case he went after what he called the
alt left which I assume means an T but
he talked about Confederate statues
being removed he talked about whether
what happened on Friday night and
Saturday was bad and then he also talked
about the people who were present at the
at the rally he was specifically about
the alright so he talked about those
four things and so we'll go through all
of those four now I will say as just a
preparatory note the fact that the left
has decided that everything that he said
yesterday was false and the right has
decided that everything that he said
yesterday was true is really
discomforting to me it's a serious
problem for me okay he said some of the
things yesterday they were true and then
he said a good many things that I think
we're actually immoral and we will talk
about all of them but I think that it is
necessary to go through in detail what
exactly he said so we can tease out what
he said was true and what he said was
false so he started off by ripping and
he feh
here is what the President had to say
about antiva what about the alt left
they came charging at the as you say the
alt right do they have any semblance of
guilt whatever we ask you this what
about the fact that came charging that
they came charging with clubs in the
hand swinging clubs do they have any
problem I think they do you know as far
as I'm concern
that was a horrible horrible day wait a
minute I'm not finished
I'm not finished fakeness that was a
horrible day I will tell you something I
watch this very closely much more
closely than you people watched it and
you have you had a group on one side
that was bad and you had a group on the
other side that was also very violent
and nobody wants to say that but I'll
say it right now you had a group you had
a group on the other side that came
charging in without a permit and they
were very very violent okay so the fact
that Trump put so much focus on what he
called the alt left here and I assume he
means antifoam when he talks about them
had the left up in arms they're saying
why aren't you focusing more on the
white supremacist rally and the fact
that a white supremacist actually was
responsible for murder rammed a car into
20 people at that at that particular
rally on Saturday why are you focusing
so much on the on the alt left I think
that it is perfectly appropriate for the
President of the United States to talk
about the violence of NPFL which has
been violent in Seattle they were
violent Seattle again yesterday violent
in Berkeley violent in Sacramento
violent in Richmond violent yesterday
okay so this is tape from yesterday this
is still in Charlottesville they're at
the courthouse and here's an Tifa
getting into it with the police
okay so Antipa has been violent and
consistently violent for a long time now
and what I'm seeing from the left is an
attempt by the left two percent that NP
f-- are the great heroes of this story
then and people are standing up to
tyranny that antia are standing up to
the alright and therefore that an tyfa
is is somehow a good force that
something good is happening with NC fine
you're seeing this from the left almost
universally this morning it's a huge
mistake by the left okay so here's your
just a couple examples mit romney right
who's not on the left but MIT Romney
tweeted this out this morning or last
night he tweeted no not the same one
site is racist bigoted not see the other
opposes racism and bigotry morally
different universes okay again it is
true that some of the protesters who
were there to protest the the white
supremacists were there and are
completely morally different universes
but Antiqua is not in a completely
morally different universe and Tifa is
it violent communist anarchist group
that's been making violent trouble all
around the country and then you had
members of the press who are mimicking
this talking point Hendrickson John
Hendrickson is a writer at Esquire
here's what he tweeted this morning he
tweeted alt left Dougs who battled Nazis
right and it's a picture of a bunch of
World War two vets hey those were not
alt left dogs those were American
soldiers who were fighting armed Nazis
who are engaged in violence and the
sovereign and the takeover of a
sovereign nation I assume that the
alt-right white supremacist neo Nazis
had actually in armed fashion taken over
Charlottesville the we'd have sent the
armed forces not an Tifa hey the alt
left is much more akin to as I said
yesterday the red mobs who were fighting
the Brown Church in 1932 Germany and
actually led to the increase in the vote
chair for Hitler's for Hitler's Nazi
Party because people got sick of
watching the Reds fight the Browns and
they sided with the Browns over the Reds
but he's not the only one making this
comparison Jeffrey Goldberg at the
Atlantic needs to be tell watching
Saving Private Ryan a movie about a
group of very aggressive outlets
protesters invading a beach without a
permit well no that's idiotic
it's about a group of American soldiers
who are invading sovereign and French
territory in order to oust the Nazis who
are an actual fighting force okay not
the same thing to compare people who are
not behaving violently in
charlottesville to people who are
behaving violently on the beaches of
France and to compare people who are
our American soldiers - alt left
protesters by the way would never join
the American army in a thousand years to
compare those people is just asinine
it's morally asinine but you saw this
this became a meme over the over the
evening Brian Fallon is a Hillary
Clinton spokesperson and here's what he
tweeted it also confronted the Nazis
without a permit and it's a picture of
the guys from World War two waiting on
to Normandy Beach insane okay same
routine from Chris Cuomo who's an anchor
over at CNN anti-fascists disrupting a
large gathering of white supremacists
and then it says let's not forget that's
what Chris Cuomo wrote and it's not just
the sort of idiots in the movement Marc
Bray is a historian here's what he wrote
in the pages of the Washington Post
today quote this is again defending n
Tifa the vast majority of the
anti-fascist organizing is nonviolent
but their willingness to physically
defend themselves and others from white
supremacists violence and preemptively
shut down fascist organizing efforts
before they turn deadly distinguishes
them from liberal anti-racist
anti-fascist argue that after the
horrors of chattel slavery in the
Holocaust physical violence against
white supremacists is both ethically
justifiable and strategically effective
the history of anti-fascist demand that
we take seriously the violence of white
supremacist the days of just ignoring
them are over and since European
anti-fascist fought Hitler and they
fought Stalin and they fought well even
said they fought Stalin actually that
would be actually incorrect they fought
Mussolini's as they fought Franco
there's only one problem with that the
anti-fascist forces who fought Hitler
and Franco and Mussolini they all lost
okay the reason one of the reasons they
all lost is because they actually made
those movements more popular by going
out there and engaging in street fights
in vimar in 1930 31 32 230 people were
killed in street clashes between the
brown shirts and the Reds in 1932 that
led to the rise of the brown shirts it
led that people wanted a restoration of
order so backing the so-called Anti Fog
rupes is really bad okay it's really bad
and keifa's tactics actually helped the
all right because it makes people see
the alt-right as victims it makes people
feel that the alt-right
are a group of people who just want to
protest non-violently and then Antipa
shows up and gets violent with them and
world war ii allies fighting hitler
shoulders soldiers were not fighting
protesters they were fighting armed men
with guns that's why we sent tanks and
howitzers to fight them we don't send
tanks and howitzers to rallies of
neo-nazis the ACLU defended Nazis by
marching in Skokie we didn't say
guys with guns the alright isn't an army
okay they're evil they believe in evil
things the minute they get violent they
should be arrested they should be put
down
but the idea that you can meet and the
idea that can meet nonviolent protests
even if people that you hate with
violence is really dangerous it's really
dangerous stuff and so when Trump says
this stuff when Trump says that an Tifa
attacked the all right and that there's
evidence of that he's correct that is
true okay that's true so that's what he
said that I think was was true in a
second I'm going to get to more what he
said about the statues and then I want
to get to what I think was the heart of
his press conference which really wasn't
that his the heart of the press
conference was him doing a soft defense
of the alt-right and really giving me
all right what they wanted I know that a
lot of people on the right are angry
with me for saying this but that's the
way I see it and I will explain in full
context why that is in just a second but
first I have to say thank you to my
friends over at Birch gold so if you are
looking at the situation in the United
States look at the situation worldwide
you're thinking boy things seem kind of
volatile this is why you should have at
least some of your assets in gold you
should have some of your assets and
precious metals Birch gold group can
help you do just that a plus rating from
the Better Business Bureau know
countless five-star reviews I mean just
an enormous number of five-star reviews
from clients they are honest and it
right if you go right now to
birchgold.com slash bet they will send
you a comprehensive 16 page kit
revealing how gold and silver can
protect your savings they can legally
move your IRA or 401k out of stocks and
bonds and into a precious metals IRA
there's never been a better time than
now to get some of your assets into into
the safe currency like gold and that's a
Birch gold group can help you do go to
birchgold.com slash bed birchgold.com
slash men they can help you move your
IRA or eligible 401k into an IRA backed
by physical gold and silver which is a
great way to protect against inflation
and uncertainty in the market again it's
birchgold.com slash them okay so moving
on in president Trump's presser so we
start off with his comments vanity for
which I think are eminently correct and
totally fine okay but there are some
problems okay and I'll get to the
problems in a second he said something
else that was true he was talking about
the movement from the left to tear down
statues
now as I said yesterday I think there's
a very solid case for taking Confederate
war memorials and moving them into
private museums moving them into private
hands you know that the idea that black
people should have to pay tax
for the upkeep of statues of people who
were attempting to keep them in slavery
I understand that argument perfectly
well and I sympathize to a large degree
that argument I also think like
Condoleezza Rice has said that ripping
away historic monuments actually
prevents people from discussing history
openly the chipping away Woodrow Wilson
off the name of buildings at Princeton
prevents us from having honest
discussions like if I would walk with my
child pass Confederate war monument it
would give me an opportunity to say look
here's the history of the country here's
how far we've come
here's what the Civil War was all about
and here's why the Confederacy deserved
to lose so you know the truth is that
when you drive through a city the vast
majority of war memorials are things
people walk right by so these are really
not flash points they've been made flash
points by two separate groups of people
black lives matter which is decided
these Confederate memorials are somehow
the the gas in the tank for racists and
racists themselves who have in
retaliation have used the Confederate
war memorials as gathering points which
is really negative and and problematic
here is a President Trump though saying
here's his bigger problem is it the left
isn't just focusing on Confederate war
memorials there is a campaign among
people on the left to go after memorials
to Thomas Jefferson the writer of the
Declaration of Independence and George
Washington who was a slave owner and
what he says here is also eminently
correct George Washington was a slave
owner was George Washington the slave
owner so will George Washington now lose
his status are we going to take down
excuse me are we going to take down are
we going to take down statues what how
about Thomas Jefferson what do you think
of Thomas Jefferson you like him okay
good are we going to take down the
statute because he was a major slave
owner now we're going to take down his
statue so you know what it's fine you're
changing history you're changing culture
okay so what he says there I think is at
least arguably correct I think what he
says there you can make a distinction I
think logically pretty easily between
robert e lee and george washington
robert e lee fought on the side of a
rebel of a rebel army attempting to
destroy the union in an attempt to
uphold slavery and George Washington was
the great preserver of the Union so
there's a pretty strong distinction
there but the case that he's making is
not wrong considering the left has
actively made the case against keeping
up statues of George Washington and
Thomas Jefferson a University
there was a big protest attempting to do
all of this there's a big protest
attempting to get rid of a statue of
Thomas Jefferson at University of
Missouri led by the black lives matter
movement so Trump isn't wrong on this
particular thing either and the right is
jumping on the two points that I've
talked about to say that everything
Trump said was correct right what he
said been on teapot is right and
condemning both sides that's fine and
the statute stopped he's right okay but
here's the problem what the President of
the United States had to do more than
anything else was stick by his statement
of Monday the statement rates and
neo-nazis and white supremacists and
their ilk these people are unacceptable
in polite society and what they say is
evil right that's that's all he had to
do is all he had to do is keep saying
that so what Trump did is he played a
double game in his press conference he
started he said I'm not talking about
neo-nazis and white supremacists I think
that they're bad right but he said also
there are a lot of good people who
showed up at these rallies and then he
also said that he didn't know what the
alt-right was somebody asked him
specifically about the alt-right and he
said he didn't know what it was so we're
going to play all of these clips and
you're going to see that Donald Trump
provided the alt-right most what it
wanted the alt-right wants to be known
not as a white supremacist group they
want their face to the public to be
we're just defending Western
civilization not white supremacism even
if they are actual white supremacists
and they want the President of the
United States to lend them credence as
though they're a bunch of very fine
people this is what the alt-right wants
okay we talked on Monday about exactly
what the alt right is the alt rights
basic Creed is that Western civilization
is inherently bound up with ethnicity
and race and that white people were the
builders of Western civilization and
therefore people of other races and
cultures cannot adapt to Western
civilization right that is the basic
argument of the alt-right Trump knows
that because his chief strategist at the
White House is Steve Bannon who helped
promulgate the outright and said that
Breitbart was in fact a platform for the
alt-right to rest quote from Steve Danon
I'm a trump played stupid and in doing
so he gave the alt-right what they
wanted he focused on the left again
that's fine but if you're going to focus
on the left you can't you can't poo poo
with you all right yeah this is the
problem on both sides the left is saying
everything he said about NTP is wrong
and the right is saying everything that
he said about NT was right and therefore
he's right or therefore he's wrong no
he's right about Antipa and he's totally
wrong about the outright and even
granting them a smidgen of credibility
is morally disgusting okay and that's
what he
yesterday to pretend otherwise is to
ignore that when Barack Obama did the
same thing to black lives matter the
right went nuts and rightly so when
Barack Obama granted credence to the
people who are burning down Ferguson in
Baltimore the right right Lee went nuts
we went nuts as well we should have we
said he was vague and Watson wait he
condemned the people rioting and we said
that wasn't enough he needed to condemn
what they were rioting about okay
President Trump really tried hard to
soft-pedal this stuff yesterday so he
started off by defending his statement
on Saturday why exactly he was asked why
didn't take till Monday for you to say
neo-nazis in the KKK and neo
Confederates were bad why didn't you
just say it on Saturday here was his
answer I had to see the facts unlike a
lot of reporters unlike a lot of
reporters out there because I know Jamie
Duke was there I wanted to see the facts
and the facts as they started coming out
were very well stated in fact everybody
said his statement was beautiful if he
would have made it sooner that would
have been good I couldn't have made it
sooner because I didn't know all of the
facts frankly people still don't know
all of the facts okay so this is
nonsense
everyone knew all the facts virtually
immediately and Tifa got violent and
then in alt-right protester drove a car
into a crowd of people who included a
bunch of innocent non Antipa people and
the alt-right people were violent as
well okay so he says he had to wait for
the facts first of all you know that's a
tell okay Trump has never ever in his
entire life had to wait for the fact
this is a guy who spends a year
proclaiming the Barack Obama without
evidence was born in Kenya this is a guy
who goes out preemptively and declares
Muslim terrorist attacks before all the
facts are in and some of that is not a
huge problem but to pretend that he is
the considerate arbiter of the fact is
just a joke okay that is not a good
excuse from President Trump it's
obviously not a good excuse you repeated
muscleman ten times in a three-minute
segment how he was waiting for all of
the facts such nonsense such an absolute
nonsense especially since we know from
Eliana and Johnson over at the
Washington Post by the way Eliana is
kind of conservative okay
she's a Clermont color when I was a
quitter my fellow Eliana johnson who
writes for The Washington Post she
reported that Trump had a statement
exactly the same as the one on Monday on
his desk
on Saturday he was standing right there
and he went off script and decided
not to say it okay so there's another
reason that Trump didn't want to do this
and that's because Trump is happy to
pander to the alright he was always
happy to pander to the alright during
the campaign he pandered to the
alt-right
he continued to pander to be alright
because he thinks that they're his
biggest supporters and they're nice to
him so he has to soft-pedal them and he
did that again yesterday who's that
specifically about the alt-right okay
the alt-right had to find it now 1,000
times they define it themselves Richard
Spencer was at this rally okay Jared
Taylor his people were at this rally the
daily stormer neo-nazis were at this
rally it was it was it was actually
pitched like this okay the ad promoting
the unite the right rally it was
designed to evoke a fascist posters with
John pine warrants right he's correct
invited speakers like Mike anok who
hosts a podcast called The Daily Show up
Augustus Invictus and all right figure
who once said I have prophesied for
years I was born for a great war that if
I had not witnessed the coming of the
second American Civil War I would begin
it myself
and Christopher Cantwell who called
himself a fascist along with Johnny
monoxide who said who calls himself a
she okay
the March the March his organizer Jason
Kessler described the views of the
people who showed up and you don't give
a damn about white people you people are
implementing policies which are
displacing us in our home countries and
we will not be allowed to survive okay
the goal of this rally was
extraordinarily clear so much so the
Gavin McInnes the head of the proud boys
and a guy with whom I've been friendly
Gavin said I will not go to this rally
because it's infused with white
supremacist and neo-nazis okay the
alt-right was a group of people who
decided to show up for this rally
because they are part of this movement
and the alt-right and here is Trump
being asked about the alt-right and here
is Trump pretending he doesn't know what
it is when you say the alt-right
define alt-right to me you define it
the militants to find it for me come on
let's go define it for me it's not a
fight how about you define it how about
you say if by the alt-right you mean X
then I then I condemn it if by the
alright you mean people who like memes I
don't alright how about he could do that
but the defensive nasaw right is really
truly incredible and then it gets even
worse and I'll show you the even worse
part in just a second but first I want
to tell you about upside calm so right
now upside calm is the best travel site
on the web you bundle your flight and
your hotel you can buy these
individually to flight in hotel and they
will get more inexpensively than other
travel sites but you save more the more
that you bundle the way that it works is
you go on their site you bundle your
flight and hotel together particularly
good for business travel and if you're
traveling alone on short notice this is
what upside calm sort of specializes in
and the way that it works is when you do
this you set up your account use your
company credit card you buy the actual
you buy the actual ticket and then under
your account pops up a gift card from
amazon.com and these gift cards go to
you right it's on your account so you
get to use that money for your own
purposes so it's not just that you save
money on the flight and hotel you also
get the kickback of the amazon.com gift
card plus their customer service is just
top-notch unlike other travel sites
where you can never get anyone on the
phone ever I won't mention the names of
other companies but you all know who I'm
talking about
they have expert navigators who are
always available 24/7 through phone chat
social and email to help anytime before
during and after a business trip to make
sure that it goes smoothly
and their concierge level of service is
second to none right now
when you go to up side calm and use
promo code been at checkout when you do
that you get a $100 gift card free from
Amazon on your package Perkin purchase
minimum purchases required but you get
that amazon.com $100 gift card
absolutely free when you use promo code
Bend to get that $100 gift card it
upside calm minimum purchases required
and you can see the site for complete
details if you're looking to travel no
better way to buy your tickets then
upside calm they are the folks who know
how to do itbest upside calm and use
that promo club and they know that we
sent you okay so as I say he went out of
his way not to condemn the alright and
then here's the part that a lot of his
allies are relying on he says that he's
condemned neo-nazis and white
supremacist but here here's what he says
I've condemned neo-nazis
I've condemned many different groups but
not all of those people were neo-nazis
believe me not all of those people were
white supremacist by any stretch
okay so combine those two statements he
doesn't know what the alt-right is and
not all of those people were neo-nazis
and white supremacist that is the
defense of the alt-right
that is an attempt to paint the
alt-right as non white supremacist non
neo-nazi that is what that is okay and
then it got worse then it got worse he
said he specifically cited the Friday
night torchlight March okay the one
where he had Richard Spencer and he had
Christopher Caldwell he had all these
people literally chanting in the street
carrying tiki torches and shouting Jews
will not replace us
right this is what he had to say about
that particular rally and if you
reported it accurately you would say I
mean you had a very bad people in that
group but you also had people that were
very fine people on both sides
you had people in that group excuse me
excuse me I saw the same pictures as you
did you had people in that group that
were there to protest the taking down of
to them a very very important statue and
the renaming of a park from robert e lee
to another name okay so again this is
really quite despicable when you look at
the actual tape okay so here is the tape
of the protests okay this is what the
protest that he is talking about or
filled with very fine people this is a
tape of the protest it to be a clip
three this is what that actually looked
like
[Applause]
Oh
person's right there yeah general advice
has some pretty good tape of all this
day the 22 minute documentary they
brought out about this the first 10
minutes is really stunning material the
rest of it is is vices bias but the
first 10 minutes of this is stunning
material here's what the rally actually
looked like on Friday night in the
center there the anti what just happened
they base week yeah I don't know one
second okay so number one you see that
Friday night that was not a lot of good
people there weren't some very fine
people marching and by the way if you
find yourself in a March just a tip to
people if you find yourself in a March
where people start shouting Jews will
not replace us maybe you should leave
maybe you should leave if you're not a
piece of garbage maybe you should leave
why is it that even the people who are
all right friendly even people who ally
with the alt-right from time to time
looked at this unite the right event and
decided not to show why is that there's
a reason for that even people like Mike
Serna metric he spent a year propping up
the alright why is the people like Mike
Stern vich said I'm not showing up why
do you think was it because it was
filled with very fine people as
president Trump says there were a lot of
very fine people okay also important to
notice on this tape the guy who's wiping
his face off here is again and
Christopher Caldwell open racist says
that president he wishes President Trump
or more racist and he's very upset the
president Trump would allow his daughter
to marry a Jew and he was maced here
again Christopher Caldwell is a
disgusting piece of garbage but macing
people is not something that you get to
do in the United States for peacefully
protesting even for evil causes here's
some more of the tape from Vice we're
here obeying the law we're doing
everything that we're supposed to do
trying to
express opinions and the criminals are
over there get in their way and that is
a that is a foundational problem our
society and whatever you think of my
opinion that's going to be something
puts you in danger and that is because
this city is run by Jewish communists
criminal we did not initiate force
against anybody we're not a nonviolent
dope you kill these people be happy
[Applause]
although he is he's saying that he'll
kill people if he has to but again this
is why auntie phones activities are
really bad okay auntie feh is just
granting credibility to the alt-right
saying oh we're just here for defensive
purposes we're just here for offensive
for okay so a lot of sorry almost curse
there a lot of really crappy people on
both sides okay that is true but it is
unfair for the President of the United
States to say that there were a lot of
very fine people who are marching on
Friday night there were not or if there
were I would like to see the evidence of
it does not mean everyone who opposes
the robert e lee statue coming down is a
bad person
okay I've said that I started the show
with that I think the Trump is not wrong
about some of the things he says about
the confederate statuary but when he
says there are a lot of very fine people
and oh what's the alt-right I've never
heard of it what does it do
okay that is really really gross and you
can see why people are reacting so
negatively to it the President of the
United States is a moral responsibility
to say not only that white supremacists
and neo-nazis are terrible and believe
terrible things but that the alt-right
is terrible particularly because they
claim him as an ally that does matter it
does matter when people claim you as an
ally it becomes a more incumbent on you
to disassociate from them if you want to
disassociate from them if somebody says
if somebody says publicly today for
example is stupid example martin
shkreli's like the weird pharmaceutical
brozac who's now in jail for fraud he
tweeted something out about how he
wanted to run for president make me his
vice president and i immediately tweeted
out if elected I will not serve if
nominated I will not run like what the
hell hey that's not my guy right that
time that's not somebody who I'm
interested in being associated with and
that's not that's a funny ridiculous
example but if you have an entire
movement of people who believe what
Christopher Caldwell believes but are
just a little quieter about it and they
claim that you support them as president
of the United States why don't you do
what Ronald Reagan did and just denounce
them and say I don't want your support I
don't want you anywhere near me but
apparently Steve Danon over the weekend
was telling Trump that he couldn't
alienate a lot of these people because
if he did then he'd lose his base the
truth is that it would actually alien a
Bandhan space but not from space okay
Trump space is very large Trump is the
President of the United States his
responsibility to stands up for everyone
in the United States and Steve Antin
space is not that large Steve Maddens
base is very alt-right driven there are
a lot of people on the alt-right who
like Bannon and see him as their great
protector and that's why Bannon is
motivate
to protect the alt-right Trump is
motivated to protect them not confuse a
racist or a neo-nazi
because Trump is motivated to sound off
in favor of any or at least protect
anybody who is ever nice to him
anybody's and this is creating a real
rift on the right that I'm going to talk
about in just a minute but for that
you're going to have to go over to Daly
wired.com you can subscribe for 9.99 a
month and nine nine in a month you get
the rest of this show live it's a video
show you can see the entire program
being part of the mailbag which will be
doing on Friday you can also engage with
the Andrew Klavan show which will be
coming up on in about 45 minutes here
over at daily wire.com you can be part
of the the michael knowles show as well
that comes on at 1:30 today I think
Michael mole is actually having on one
of the people who was one of the white
supremacists or all right people 12:30
okay he's having on one of the alt-right
folks he showed up at this rally at in
in Charlottesville so that should be
interesting so you should check that out
as well you get all of that for $9.99 a
month plus you get an annual
subscription then you get this most
magnificent of tumblers leftist here's
hot or cold daily water tumbler you'll
treasure it you'll pass it down to your
children as Malthus has suggested there
are rumors unconfirmed that it is made
from Valyrian steel it is it can in fact
kill White Walkers so if you are in the
middle of a battle with zombies then
this may come in handy as well so
protect yourself by getting one of these
for $99 and the nation so make sure they
go over to iTunes and SoundCloud listen
subscribe we must review at iTunes it
helps us with the with the ratings and
the rankings and the listenership the
additional publicity gains us more
listeners we are the largest
conservative podcast in the nation
[Music]
okay so all of this has created a rift
on the right there's no rift on the left
because the left is fully willing to go
all the way with an Tifa because of the
left because of the left's willingness
to go all the way with an Tifa there's a
reactionary side to the right that says
okay well the alt-right isn't that bad
like what Trump said yesterday wasn't
that bad
there wasn't anything morally wrong with
it you see people are so hesitant to
alienate sort of the hard core all right
Trump support base and that's not that's
a small percentage of Trump supporters
by the way the vast majority of Trump
supporters are not alright support it's
a very small group of people but people
are so hesitant to alienate that they
are hesitant to condemn in moral terms
what the president did yesterday and
what he did was immoral yesterday it was
an immoral thing the president did
yesterday by pretending he didn't know
what the alt-right was and then
suggesting that there were very fine
people who showed up for that rally on
Friday night and then suggesting that
not all those people were white
supremacists and putting this sort of
equal focus on the what he called the
alt left with the with the all right
again the alt left the the NP faux
groups are evil but it was an all right
guy who murdered someone on Saturday it
was an all right guy who drove a car
into a crowd and murdered a woman and
killed and hurt 19 other people there is
plenty of time to discuss the evil to
man Tifa there's plenty of time to
discuss the evils of leftist violence we
do it on the show routinely you know
yesterday it's fine dimension Antiques
is violent it is not fine
to either equate the activities of the
two at these particular rallies or to
suggest that the or to suggest that the
alright was not a part of this it's it
it's what they all record of wished for
the proof was in the pudding both
Richard Spencer and David Duke
celebrated president from statements
yesterday if I were President Trump I
wouldn't want David Duke or Richard
Spencer celebrating me for any reason
Under the Sun in any case this is broken
out into into an intellectual fight on
the right Laura Ingraham who of course
has been a very very strong supporter of
President Trump throughout the campaign
and was talking about as press secretary
when she was on Fox News and she said
well the big problem is that this
doesn't forward the president's policy
agenda I always like to think about it
this way
is he advancing his agenda that's what
happened this afternoon and I will say
when you had Gary Cohen up there talking
about they're going to hit the ground
running on tax reform we're ready we
spent the whole day doing it
I was like I wanted to hear more and
more and more that's great and we got
sidetracked on this horrific event of
the weekend which he had made the
subsequent statement about that was I
think really really good I think he
could have been more specific clearly on
Saturday but when he said we must love
each other show affection for each other
unite together and condemn that hatred
bigotry of the violence that we thought
that was so great yesterday I think
today he's really torched about people
conflating Trump's support with white
nationalists you can see it and hear it
as responsive and I understand that but
he's not there to win every debating
point people want to see a calm
president in the storm I think today why
think he made some points that were
factually right there were the word lot
that was violence on both sides in that
event on Saturday anyone who's watched
the video could see it okay what she
says there is not all wrong but it is
also a massive misdirect and that's what
Krauthammer immediately comes back
ancestry says you know that is that it's
really a cop-out to say that what Trump
said yesterday was wrong because it
distracts from his agenda
he's a real cop at what he did wrong
yesterday was wrong it was just wrong I
mean it was a morally wrong thing to do
so Krauthammer says that and then Ingram
immediately comes back by doing this
this tired boring talking point where
she says that anybody who's just
satisfied with anything Trump does it's
just because they hate Trump personally
I am so bored with this bull crap I
can't even tell you the fact is I want
the same things that Laura Ingraham
wants in terms of policy at least 70% of
the way the idea that I'm sitting there
rooting for Trump to fail is nonsense I
want Trump to do the right thing I want
him to do the right thing not only for
the agenda but morally I want him to do
the right thing I want him to do the
ethically right thing I want him to come
out and condemn the all right I want the
alt-right exercise I think there are
cancer on our movement I want him to
call out mpfi celebrate him calling out
an Tifa but he needs to also call out
the people who are evil within his own
movement and if he won't do that clearly
and concisely not just 99 times out of
100 not just I'm irritated having to do
it it should be easy okay I remember a
couple of weeks ago I was on with the
Dana Perino on Fox News debating some
guy from care and I said why don't you
condemn the Muslim Brotherhood and he
said why don't you condemn the KKK I
said sure the KKK is going to garbage
human beings without any skin off my
nose did I feel bad about that defi like
oh how dare he demand that I did who
cares
defend bad
condemned bad people why is this
difficult it's not difficult it's such a
gimme it's such a gimme and the fact
that he didn't do it is immoral it's
immoral you can see that people around
who know it here's tape of John Kelly
okay John Kelly his new White House
chief of staff the guy who's going to
save the Trump administration from
Trump's sort of chaos this is actual
tape of John Kelly an honorable man
reacting to president Trump's press
conference yesterday was beautiful is
what if they as soon as ever vision I
couldn't make it sir because they didn't
jump all of the facts frankly people
still don't know it was very important
to me to get the facts up and correct
because if I would have benefited and
the first thing we paint without really
much other than what we would see the
second look how uncomfortable is it not
what were the many side you were talking
about sorry still sighs mr. president
okay Kelly did this for 15 minutes it
was just him staring into the abyss for
15 minutes Kelly was not a happy camper
nor should he have been nor should he
have been and I'm tired of this cop-out
that you know if he does something
immoral it's only a distraction from
polity immoral things are immoral and
also tired of this cop-out that if I
think something he did is immoral it's
because I want him to fail or I'm
anti-trump he's the president I want him
to succeed he's the president I want him
to do good things
just enough now the media is not helping
any of this of course because the media
have decided not just condemn Trump for
doing what he's obviously doing
pandering to the all right but they have
decided that it is important to call him
an actual Nazi so Jimmy Kimmel suggested
that President Trump cuts eye holes out
of his venture use natural member of the
KKK
that's another another disturbing Monday
in America you know we went into the
weekend worrying about Kim Jong Un's
starting a war we came out of it
wondering if our president is cutting
eyeholes out of his bed sheets
you know as you know this weekend of
Virginia the worst people in the United
States went to the hardware store bought
tiki torches lit them up in March in
Charlottesville and nonviolent
protesters was killed by a white
supremacist and to the president who is
the president by the way went on
television to say this we condemn in the
strongest possible you know it's gone
with Kimmel Big E you can see the Kimmel
is obviously calling Trump a Nazi David
Axelrod who was the the former White
House communications director I believe
under President Obama he was his
campaign strategist in 2008 he said that
Trump bleached the white robes of the
KKK listen this this press conference
was in every way shape and form a car
wreck for the president it showed a guy
who was melting down it showed a guy who
was small-minded intemperate and sending
dog whistles to white supremacists and
neo-nazis which is why they have thanked
him for his comments I mean he he was
bleaching their white robes and he was
shining their shields with his remarks
today and he may say he condemned them
but that's not the way anybody in
America read that it's the idea that
this is the idea that from Axelrod is of
course that Trump isn't doing this for
political gain he's doing this because
he actually sympathizes with white
supremacism
I don't think that's what's going on
with Trump and this is one of the things
that's bothered me about the leftist
take on all this it bothered me with
Steve Danon
okay Steve Annan is a guy I know and
personally dislike very strongly I think
Steve's a bad human being but when
people said that Steve was a racist or
an anti-semite I had to say I don't see
any evidence of that I do see evidence
that he's willing to pander to those
groups for political gain the left can't
just stick to the truth they cannot just
stick to the truth I've been saying this
for a year okay they can't just stick to
the truth of what's going on they have
to declare not only that Trump is a Nazi
but everyone who supports him as a Nazi
everybody on the right is a Nazi and
then an Tifa is a group of glorious
World War two allies who are fighting
the bad guys okay and keifa shut down a
rally in Portland or a bunch of
Republicans just wanted to march in the
Rose Parade as they do every year but
this is what the left is doing I said
this yesterday both of the radical the
rabbit of the left is embracing the
radical left and the right in response
is increasingly winking and nodding at
the radical right
and and I don't even think that the
alright is right but I think that they
are Trump supporters in the main because
they see in Trump and Ally against the
sjw's and and against political
correctness and it's dangerous on both
sides it's getting more dangerous at the
very least can we start with no violence
can we start with an Tifa should be
arrested when they commit acts of
violence and then we'll talk about how
everybody in the United States needs to
condemn including the President of the
United States need to come out and and
cut out the cancer that is the alt right
okay all right is the cancer there
blight I mean and in fact the president
will do that is it's so disheartening I
can't in some days it's very hard to do
the show because it's so disheartening
when you see the moral the moral
emptiness on both sides of the political
aisle for partisan gain it really is
quite horrifying to me and I'm I'm as
conservative as anyone in America and I
find this to end and not only do I think
that that you know in spite of my
conservatism I think all this stuff is
terrible I think because of my
conservatism I think all the stuff is
terrible conservatives believe in
individual liberty and individual value
we believe in the idea that human beings
were made in God's image each and every
one of us we believe in the idea of
respect and tolerance for other people's
views we believe in the idea the best
views will win we believe in the idea
that the government shouldn't get
involved in the stuff because we believe
all the things I just mentioned and if
we if we are willing to wink and nod at
all of these bad things in order to
advance in order to advance our agenda
on either side then we're just we're
part of the problem we'll make in the
country a lot worse place it's really
it's really horrifying okay what that
said time for some things I like some
things I hate in a quick Bible so quick
Bible study so things I like over the
weekend they had a chance to read a
highly recommended book called the
sojourn by Andrew Quebec and there's a
book about world war 1 and it's about a
guy who is he grows up very very young
in the United States and then he moves
back to Czechoslovakia or what becomes
Czechoslovakia and ends up joining up
with the austro-hungarian army in World
War one it's a very beautifully written
novel it's very spare it's very
reminiscent of A Farewell to Arms by
Hemingway and it's already being counted
as sort of a world of one classic he
apparently wrote a sequel that I'm
looking forward to reading about Vietnam
War it's called the sojourn by Andrew
Kovac good piece of fiction and it
reminds us that despite
partisan fights and there are certain
human values that we should hold dear
together it's very good book go out and
buy it okay time for some things that I
think so I've been I've been focusing a
lot on sports TV lately because it seems
like everything is becoming more more
politicized and so Stephen H Smith has
come in for some heavy criticism on the
show recently yesterday Stephen a Smith
suggested that the race of a protester
grants that protester legitimacy or
illegitimacy here's Stephen hmm
suggesting that white people should
never be able to tell black people not
to protest no white person has the right
to tell black folks wayne you should
protest about something because usually
protests that emanates from the black
community is due in large part because
of the transgressions exactly against
that community by those who don't happen
to be black and then you wonder why
there's an alt right now you want to
right there's a white identity politics
white people can never tell black people
not to protest for any reason so what
about when white people say the same
thing what about when the alt Rights is
the same thing what about when the
alt-right white identity disgusting
human being say well black people can't
tell us not to protest after all there
are policies like affirmative action why
should how can they tell us that went on
the victims this is what's wrong with
the country but this is happening in the
mainstream okay that's not a march
around a robert e lee statue in in the
middle of virginia this is on national
TV on ESPN Stephen H Smith is a sports
commentator this sort of stuff makes the
country worse it makes the country worse
okay one more thing that I hate so Iran
is now threatening a nuclear restart
Thank You Obama administration thank you
on August 15th Iran's president warned
it could restart its nuclear program
within hours or days if the Trump
administration continues its
confrontational policy toward the
Islamic Republic I thought that we were
guaranteed that Iran was now going to be
non-nuclear I thought that everything
was going to be hunky-dory now yeah no
it turns out that when you deal with
evil people when you cut deals with evil
people you end up with with the crap in
your lap and that's basically what's
happened here okay so time for a very
quick Bible study a little bit of
inspirational uplift in the middle of a
very dark week so as I mentioned every
week that we've been going through not
the Torah but the haftorah the tour is
the five books of Moses every week the
Jews also read a portion from
the prophets and the writings that
corresponds to the portion from the
Torah reading we do that because back in
Roman times Jews were not allowed to
read from the Torah they were barred
from reading from the Torah so instead
they started reading references from the
prophets and the writings that people
could could easily cross-reference to
the Torah itself so this comes courtesy
of Isaiah this is chapter 54 of Isaiah
incline your ear and come to me hearken
and your soul shall live and I will make
for you an everlasting covenant the
dependable mercies of David behold a
witness to nations I have appointed
appointed him a ruler and a commander of
nations he's talking about King David
messianic era may idea that eventually
there will be a messianic era in which
the kingdom of David will shine forth
there's a part that I think is really
interesting here is where he says behold
a witness to nations I have appointed
him a ruler and commander we tend to
think about the messianic age a lot as
the idea that that good will rule and
command but it's not just that it's
about witnessing and this is something
we should all take to heart okay we are
all witnesses we are not just about
ruling we're not just about power it's
not just about who controls the levers
of power we are all witnesses to good
and evil we all are going to be called
on by God to testify when our time comes
as to whether we stood up or whether we
stood with or whether we stood against
and we are all witnesses
we're witnesses to all the things that
go on around us and to shut our eyes to
blind ourselves that we are not called
upon to witness is part of the problem
we are all part of this together if we
don't witness evil and speak out about
it if we're not able to testify even on
our own behalf as to what we think about
bad things that are happening then we
don't deserve the Messianic era let
alone good in the afterlife or even good
on this planet I think that as people
who are delegated at certain
responsibility by God and and by our
fellow man we have to stand up to evil
when we see it we have to call it out
when we see it okay we'll be back here
tomorrow hopefully we'll have a good day
of news how about that'd be nice
wouldn't it and then we can do something
fun please mr. president please mediate
please for the love of God can we have a
nice day I'm Ben Shapiro this is the Ben
Shapiro show
you